hello everyone and welcome to a very
special day for the chess world it is
the birthday of the greatest chess
player who ever lived that is of course
the pirate of latvia uh or the the
pirate of riga uh the mikhail tal here
he is the uh protector of this channel
and yeah there are a lot of games to
choose from of course some of them we
covered some of them we still haven't uh
this one i haven't covered and it's very
very enjoyable it's from 1981 and tal is
playing against hungarian grand master
janus flesh or maybe tiano
yeah it could be also janoshia i'm i'm
going to go with janos on this one janos
flesh
and uh
he is he had he does have the title of
grand master but i think it's a title of
an honorary grandmaster so i think he's
an international master within with the
title of an honorary grandmaster so this
is uh one of the games that i still
haven't shown on this channel and for
those of you who are new to chess or new
to this channel
i welcome uh you all and i invite you to
check out some of uh tells the greatest
games i will put two playlists in the
description below it will be the first
thing you will see uh so first one is uh
the 1959 candidates tournament so you
guys absolutely have to check out that
one you could all you could just watch
tal's games but i i suggest you watch
everyone's games as i pretty much
covered all the all the interesting ones
because there are you know a lot of very
interesting fisher games there are some
dismissal of games that are very good
and uh well many of the other players of
course uh paul karis so you do not want
to miss uh keras games and also i will
put a link to the playlist uh
tal versus between the the 1960 world
chair championship match so do check it
out if you guys want to learn a bit more
about tal so that being said let's check
out the game and i i thought about maybe
uh you know repeating some of the games
that i've already shown but we're going
to wait for you know technology to you
know improve a little bit more until i
rework all of my previous work so let's
check it out tal versus flash uh this is
1981 and let's check it out so tau opens
with e4 as he usually does we have c6
flash goes for
the karo khan defense with d for d5 and
now knight to c3 so d captures on e4
knight captures on e4 and knights the d7
so this is the carpal variation and it's
uh still played to this day uh knight to
f3 and knight to g to f6 now attacking
the knight on e4 and now you could just
defend it you could capture on f6 stall
brings the knight back knight's the g3
he wants to keep as many pieces on the
board as one would expect
from such an attacker but for those of
you who don't know jana's flesh is also
um
well he also has a reputation of being a
fierce attacker and he really likes the
attack and he enjoys complicated
positions so uh this is a this is a
great matchup so here we have e6 bishop
to d3 ended now uh the most annoying
move when playing against the karo khan
this delayed c5 now challenging white
center uh we have c3 defending the
center and now c captures on d4 we have
knight captures on d4 uh you don't want
to capture with the pawn then we have an
isolated d-pawn so this is maybe a
little bit better and the bishop the c5
now and now tal castles
so now if you capture on d4 yes you can
create an isolator the d-pawn but then
you give up the bishop pair so maybe not
something you want to
do
and usually black just castles here but
uh in this game uh janusz actually
captured on d4 he played bishop captures
on d4 so he gives up the bishop pair and
he wants to play against this isolated
d-pawn so let's see how tall uh goes
about this we have c captures on the e4
and here uh janos castles and the bishop
to g5 we have to keep developing our
pieces until we're fully developed
and now h6 now a useful move we want to
get rid of this bishop asking tal where
is the bishop headed and also uh we do
not want this h71 to be a target anytime
soon so bishop back to f4 now also uh
the d6 square could be important at some
point and now comes knight to b6 and it
is now only as a move 13 that this
position was never repeated again
and now you could uh okay it seems like
the d4 pawn is hanging but not really
you could just play rook to c1 rook to
e1 just you know continue development
and if the pawn is captured the bishop
h7 check and you you blunder your queen
so you could start by developing but the
top plays bishop to c2 it's a very
sneaky move you're preparing some like
queen to d3 bishop e5 captures you can
deliver checkmate with queen to h7 so
it's a
uh you know it's a
it's it's a barbarian move but it's uh
it's a move that someone like tal would
play so it's an annoying move and you
have to deal with this it's it's a
concrete threat
uh so knight b to d5 putting pressure on
the bishop here and bishop to e5 now
putting pressure on the knight and now
queen to b6 now uh what do you do here
uh well here tal just plays queen to d3
now the thread is uh uh if for example
this knight moves we can capture on f6
and deliver checkmate via queen to h7
but there is the problem of knight to b4
of course attacking the queen and the
bishop and if you're thinking about
grabbing the b2 pawn
that's just terrible here we can capture
the knight and after the knight is
captured rook f2b1 tribes the queen so
we can't play this the queen covers the
a3 square so after queen to d3 knights
to b4 we want to get rid of this
annoying setup here it's all created on
c2 and d3 so queen back to d2 ended now
uh you have to decide whether you can
really capture this bishop because
obviously tal is planning something it's
not just that you know he's uh you know
hitting his
head against the wall so you could
consider knight to g4 because bishop
captures an f6 is also one of white's
threats now that would open up the black
king uh but still uh flesh goes for a
knight captures on c2 the thing is if
you go knight to g4 then we can even
play bishop captures on g7 and after
king captures knight h5 check and after
king h8 even h3 now uh trying to get rid
of the defender of the h6 pawn and even
though this might be playable the the
engine thinks this is okay for black you
do not want to play something uh like
this against tal so after queen to d2 we
have knight captures on c2 but now 12
plays bishop captures on f6 of course he
doesn't care about the rook on a1 and
you don't really have this luxury of
declining the rook if you play g
captures on f6 then we play queen
captures on h6 and it's game over
there's no defense knight stage 5 is
coming you could try some like queen b5
but still then knight d4 uh
preventing queen to g5 or going for the
f6 pawn and there's no defense here
you're gonna have to give up your queen
just uh uh prevent checkmate so instead
after bishop captures an f6 we have uh
knight captures on a1 uh there simply
isn't anything better and now
doesn't recapture on a1 tal doesn't move
the bishop just continues mounting the
attack with knight to h5 now the g7 pawn
is hanging and uh how do we deal with
this well the bishop cannot be captured
if you capture the bishop queen captures
an h6 and that's it there's no defense
against this checkmate so here we have
e5 uh white uh black decides to give up
one point
uh
get some contra chances now the queen
gets access to the sixth rank and also
you will be able to bring your light
square bishop into the game so tau
accepts this we have d captures an e5
and now g5 getting rid of this uh
problematic uh
pawn on g7 and now uh it seems like
black solved all of his problems but
there still is one thing to worry about
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this incredible uh move that
can only be characterized as a tall move
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on always looking for
that opportunity to give your opponent
some material and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course ponte e6 style is disgusted at uh
you know this pawn that was given to him
and he just wants to give it back uh but
there there's a great idea behind this
because with the pawn on e6 uh you've
cut off the queen's defense of the sixth
rank and also how do you deal with this
you could capture with the pawn you
could capture with the bishop and you
could capture with the queen so let's
try capturing with the pawn uh that's
just terrible just queen d3 and there's
really nothing you can do uh here if
rook captures on f6 we're going to play
knight captures on f6 king g7 now knight
h5 check uh all of these squares are now
nicely covered by the queen by the
knight so you have to play something
king of faith rook to d1 and now the
queen can you know easily join the
attack and it's going to be a game over
very quickly so f captures an e6 doesn't
really work if bishop captures an e6
this is playable but then we go for this
bishop captures on g5 because that's our
our whole plan here just bishop captures
on g5 and we do not wanted the queen to
have access to the to the sixth rank or
that um you know g6 square
and the bishop nicely blocks this so now
we'll we'll probably see some like queen
to c5 and now knight f6 check king to h8
now bishop to h4 and now we're
threatening queen captures on h6 so we
have to defend this king to g7 now queen
d3 we're threatening checkmate here and
after this is prevented with bishop to
f5 something like queen to g3 check and
now bishop g6 is the only good move for
black here we're going to play knight to
d7 attack the rook attack the queen
bishop f6 is an option queen can maybe
come to c3 if the black queen moves from
the from the c file and it's not going
to be easy for black to survive this
attack so obviously after this e6 move
you can't capture with the pawn you
can't capture with the bishop so your
only option is to capture it with the
queen you absolutely have to capture it
with something so queen captures on e6
was played and now only now we have h3
so taking away the g4 square from the
black queen and uh just asking black
what do you play here so it's a really
really uh you know you really have to
appreciate tal's uh brain here because
he he plays the move like e6 only to
follow it up by a move like h3 he's
saying yes you're up the exchange but uh
you know nothing is really happening
here i can always capture this knight on
a1 uh what do you play here well we have
queen to f5 black really wants to get
his queen to g6 to get rid of this
knight from h5 so rook captures on a1
tal wasn't really interested in this
knight but black just uh you know uh
plays such moves that uh he doesn't have
anything better than to grab the
material
we have bishop to e6 black continues
development and now rook back to e1 uh
we have queen to g6 now threatening to
capture the knight and g4 now and the
knight is nicely defended and now rook
to c8 now black can also start
developing his pieces he's preparing to
bring the rook to c2 maybe double up on
the c file so tal needs to prevent this
he plays bishop to c3 now uh you will
not be able to
play rook to c2 but also knight to f6 is
a terrible threat if knight to f6 comes
the bishop and the knight will be
controlling all of these squares and
that's just game so you have to free up
the f8 square for the black king so here
we have rook f2d8 with tempo the white
queen is attacked queen to e3 and now
rook to d3 attacking the queen again
queen to e5 now threatening queen h8
checkmate and there is nothing enough
for black to do other than to give up
the rook for this beautiful bishop on c3
so rook c captures in c3 b captures on
c3 and now
it's uh it's a critical position and
black has only one move that allows him
to continue the game he's going to be
worse but you know he's going to be
allowed to continue the game and that
move is of course a bishop to c4 uh he
did not find this move but it's uh it's
a really tricky move to find i'll show
you why
uh in the game king the h7 was played
and now tal has this uh you know it is
just uh
a matter of the hanging rook on d3 the
rook and d3 is not actually hanging
but uh you know it it really is uh so
here knight to f6 check king to g7 and
now knight to d5 a discovery here you
have to move the king king to h7 and now
knight to e7 attacking the queen and now
the queen has to move away from this
diagonal all of the squares are covered
and you can't keep an eye on that rook
so here queen to g7 and the queen to e4
with check
just uh ready to pick up this rook on d3
and now we're just gonna sidestep a few
moves uh backwards the uh to that
position at mul 29 where we discussed
that bishop to the bishop to c4 is the
only move for black and now you know why
so after all of this is said and done uh
knight f6 check uh came to g7 we're
going to play knight to d5 with checking
to h797 uh the rook is guarded and we
free up the e6 square for the black
queen that's why this is the only
defense so let's go back there uh we
have queen to e4 with check the rook is
uh hanging now we have f5 attacking the
queen hoping for rook for hoping for
queen captures rook and then we're going
to capture the knight on e7 but tal just
happily grabs the f5 pawn now threatens
to you know pick up the bishop pick up
the rook if if queen captures an e7 we
can even play f6 check pick up the queen
so nothing is really working here for
black bishop captures on f5 was played
now comes queen captures an f5 with
check king to h8 and now knight to g6
with check it's actually a force to
check made in six here for for tal uh so
he goes for a knight to g6 check now if
you go to g8 then it's just rook to e8
to check king to h7 and now the very
nice knight e5 uh discovery check queen
g6 and queen captures and g6 is
checkmate so after knight the g6 king
the h7 was played now knights the h4
with check many discoveries are are good
this just seems like the nicest one to
play king h8 now comes rook to e8 with
check
queen to g8 and now not even capturing
the queen but knight to g6 would check
it's important to deliver checkmate in
the uh you know uh uh least number of
moves uh and now if king to g7 were of
course going to play rook to a7 check
and now you have to block and then queen
captures and f7 is checkmate so after
this check king the h7 was played but
it's pretty much the same thing only now
we play knight to the e7 check open up a
discovery here queen to g6 and now queen
to g6 checkmate without ever even
capturing this rook on d3
and yeah i might even use this as a
thumbnail because it's just a you know
complete mess of a position
uh so yeah that's the game tal versus
flash 1981 uh really really
an enjoyable one like i said uh there
are many games um uh towel plate that we
can enjoy i i covered many of them which
you guys are welcome to you know
re-watch but uh you know we're gonna
wait for for technology to improve a
little bit more before i uh
remake them at like you know maybe two
240 frames per second or something like
that
or maybe in vr or you know who who knows
who knows what
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it and yeah very happy 85th
birthday to tamisha uh i would also uh
like to wish a very happy birthday to
dummy and a very happy birthday to luis
i hope you guys have a great day filled
with uh you know chess enjoy and in case
you guys didn't know you guys shared the
birthday with the greatest chess player
who ever lived uh the pirate of riga
mikhail tal and i would also like to
thank michael kennedy david kimura and
rafael zamora for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else is
happening in the chess world uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and do check
out the two links in the description
below for more tile games see you soon